dans l'espace je sais pas comment on s'y
prend pour s'alimenter mais certainement
que l'on ne mange pas comme nous les
terriens sur nos tables c'est l'objet de
notre entretien avec notre invité qui
nous sommes avec plaisir pierre
desproges
à propos d'un sondage que publie cuisine
evans france dont il est un des
collaborateurs d'ailleurs un sondage de
la sofres sur le goût des français on
pourrait le résumer ainsi qu' on
pourrait dire dis moi ce que tu bouffes
et je te dirai qui tu es
je te dire à quel parti tu appartiens
puisque dans ce sondage de la sofres
on a cherché à savoir quel était le plat
favori des français mais aussi à savoir
si le millefeuille était de droite si
les socialistes avaient les mêmes
préférences que leurs alliés communistes
alors pierre vous nous avez sélectionné
quelques menus qui conviennent plus
particulièrement un communiste un
socialiste est quelqu'un de la droite
louis expliqué je n'ai rien inventé j'ai
repris le terme du sondage en gros il
ressort de ce sondage culinaire que les
français ont besoin de simplicité on le
sent aussi dans le discours politique de
monsieur puck du cigare il a enlevé la
crème
ils ont ils dit plus française français
et dix français tout court rist un
nouveau langage et il a raison
d'ailleurs ces deux françaises français
c'est une faute
syntaxin mais bon il ya de la simplicité
et waco joie brigitte simonetta sans son
rouge à lèvres les ravissantes quand
même pour revenir à la cuisine
tchernenko sucre des phrases sans sucre
centre m et puis alors pour en fournir
directement ce sondage
je me suis amusé à partir donc je dis ce
sondage été élaboré en prenant les gens
parlent par sexe par tranches d'âge et
par opinions politiques ce qui est assez
amusant de penser à la bouffe par
rapport aux appartenances politiques des
années sombres en tranches d'âgés où il
faille et les tranches science exacte
alors je pensais moi ce qui m'intéresse
de draguer généralement dans la vie
quand j'ai le temps et alors pour
draguer la table en france c'est très
important alors un partant de ce sondage
j'établis deux menus types par exemple
pour draguer une femme rpr et de 40 ans
alors je dis 40 ans s'est passé lâche
que je préfère mon peuple il ya peu de
femmes et reperdent de moins de 40 ans
est un homme bon quand même autre chose
à faire avant alors si vous voulez
draguer
pères vous lui servez en apéritif du
champagne ça c'est impératif
j'adore la champagne les coques des
coquilles saint-jacques beaucoup de la
seule normande que vous arrosez de
nouveau de champagne alors qu'à mon avis
une faute de goût je suis pas ce qu'en
penserait jean ferniot qui travaillent
dans le même journal que moi mais ne
devrait pas servir champagne à table
mais bon elle aime bien sérieux femmes
et repère de 40 ans on lui donnait pas
de fromage
ça sent pas bon il remettait du
champagne à la place du fromage oui et
vous terminez par une charlotte aux
fraises bien et même me sens même si
c'est une communiste le nom bien
charlotte aux fraises mais alors
justement qu'est que proposez vous à une
femme communiste du même âge de 40 à
nantes à lyon alors à l'aller elle est
plurielle du plus vieil non parce les
femmes commis ces 50 ans parce que c'est
rare maintenant de trouver des phocéens
correspond à l'âge de la ménopause
l'engagement communiste chez les femmes
actuellement alors donc pour draguer une
femme que multi 50 ans alors ça c'est
curieux c'est pas de ma faute mais il
faut du tout les servir tout rouge
martini oui elles s'aiment bien europa
symbolique oui à wil elle adore les
thomistes aime beaucoup les femmes comme
il aime le homard qu'il rouge également
ses formes en 2d de ma faute
le gigot saignant donc également rouge
le bordeaux rouge également comme
fromage je les aime bien les camemberts
de préférence pas citer de marque si
vous ne faites obligé de passer
l'information
le camembert le petit hic est rouge et
la charlotte aux fraises rouge également
voilà c'est drôle m'enfin moi
personnellement je rate pas alors
communiste de peur d'attraper la roja
les draps et maintenant la femme
socialiste alors j'ai pas j'ai pas vu ça
de près et là vous me prenez de cours je
peux longtemps d'étudier de très près de
très près non ce que j'ai noté d'autres
je sais que les femmes socialistes les
socialistes aiment le gigot 44 46 % je
pense parce qu'il aime bien tenir le
manche le clou encore spatz un rapport
et vous vous avez une recette dans ce
dans ce magazine qui s'appelle la cigale
melba proulx et personne c'est quoi ça
oui moi ce sont google
je connais pas par coeur là c'est pas
choisi un très bref la cigale melba oui
c'est un c'est une recette qui je sais
que ça fait grincer certaines et
certains lecteurs pour un vieux lecteurs
de ce journal mais c'est très bon quand
même
alors pour faire une cigale melba vous
comptez une douzaine de cigales noter un
des cigales de la vanne c'est bien sûr
les meilleurs
où les enfoncer vivante dans un teckel
que vous aurez préalablement use les
pour inviter les morsures évidemment
vous jetez le teckel dans un ferry avec
deux litres d'eau salée quand l'eau
frémit le teckel aussi s'ils se sauvent
vous faites revenir avec un oignon à
l'aide d'une écumoire vous chassez le
naturel
attention s'il revient de galop c'est
pas un teckel c'est un cheval en fin de
cuisson vous passez au chinois
si vous n'avez pas de chinois vous
passez au [ __ ]
et puis vous servez assez vite vous
maintenant des preuves merci j'espère
que les téléspectateurs ont bien noté 7
cette recette de pierre desproges pierre
voulu reporter en province pour faire
notre stabilité ferme
oui je vais tourner je commence à
limoges oui début octobre l'orangerie me
promener en france et bien figurer